netflix apparently wants to break into
the video games business experts say
it's a bad idea so this is a business
insider story
with over 200 million paid subscribers
worldwide netflix is an absolute
behemoth
so what's next for netflix the answer to
the question at least
in part appears to be video games
netflix is fishing around for a gaming
executive
to help it expand out its gaming
initiative while we still don't
know how much about netflix's plans one
thing is clear right now netflix getting
involved in gaming
is almost certain to fail huh i do think
they will try
and do think they will fail wed bush
managing director
uh told insider of michael patcher told
insider
it's hard to make games indeed the video
game industry is a very
risky business and even entrenched
studios with top tier talent and years
of experience regularly go under
we have the failures of thq midway
acclaimed 3do
bam adios atari info games
in airplane and probably a few others to
illustrate how hard it is
patrick said i don't see how netflix
could possibly think it can develop and
sell
games thoughts i don't like it i don't
know why they have to do it i'm a big
fan of staying in your lane i mean you
have to evolve
at times but i mean you got 200 million
subscribers how about focusing on a
little bit better content because i love
netflix it's great but
you know they could they could acquire
some even better content here along the
way
you know there are there's a lot of case
studies of companies that have failed at
this you mentioned them but even google
amazon and facebook
have spent hundreds of millions of
dollars trying to come up with gaming
and it doesn't work i mean coca-cola
right it's a very
good company they don't dabble in
persian rugs right
you know four seasons doesn't sell
lawnmowers i mean stay out of the gaming
industry and work even harder on the
content
now i'm saying this as a non-gamer yeah
so it's all tempered in that see i
actually i think it's ambitious
and i think that they have the money to
play with and i think it's a good idea
frankly
i think that they have a lot of problems
you're a gamer yeah i like gaming yeah
but i i think are you a regular gamer
are you like every week you're gonna
play
i was before i was a valuetainer now i
work 80 hours a week so good
and you're losing weight when you're
healthy
his tinder profile is going to change i
benched 515
pounds which one the the the republican
one of the non-binary one
pat do you realize how many came in you
would have begged to win
i wish i could show you off off uh by
here i wish i could show the people i
got i matched with a girl on hinge here
in fort lauderdale and she dumped me
in 120 seconds i lasted what i lasted
less than two minutes with this girl
well that's industry standard yeah
if you're if you're an investor in
netflix how are you not pissed off by
this because there's a 95
chance they're going to fail i need to
know more information gaming
people think that it's it's going to be
this massive open world game
grand theft auto if they're going to try
to compete on that level it's a bad idea
but if if they're gaming if they're
going to gamifica uh gamificate
their their shows it's a good idea like
what they did with
bandersnatch in uh in in black mirror if
they're going to to get into
interactive movies that they have
already with cut scenes
and it's going to go back to like the
old school remember when we were kids
and there were books
if you think he did this turn the page
79 if they're going to have
the game if they're going to gamify
their shows it's a really
really good idea that's innovative yeah
but disney failed at that as well they
tried to game
gamify their ip and it didn't work
that's g that's disney though they also
tried to wokify everything and everybody
left so let me ask this question kai
i'm asking this from you uh david are
you gamer or no are you do
do you game yeah yeah you're a gamer kai
are you a gamer
would you consider yourself a gamer
somewhat uh not really casually maybe
casual do you play every week or no
uh no do you play i agree with kai we
get more casually
so what do you think about netflix and
gaming i'm curious let's ask a different
generation what do you guys think about
gaming
netflix going into gaming i mean it
makes sense if you can i mean
now games are moving more into like a
streaming where you can stream things
yeah
and so if netflix is popular for
streaming it makes sense
but i agree with tom in a sense just
doubling down on what you're
known for doing great at some of their
eyepieces are made for games like that
movie bright would have been a better
game than a movie
they have that it's called light bright
uh so i think i think it depends
because going into gaming is very vague
it's not necessarily that they're making
video games they could be trying to
compete with steam which is a platform
where you
buy games same way as they do for
netflix where you have subscription
models so you pay a subscription
and you have access to a wide range of
games as long as you
keep paying for the subscription um so
i'd i'd have to
want to know more specifically what are
they aiming for as opposed to just
throwing out or to kai's point let's say
that they were trying to integrate
steam with stitch where you buy the game
on their platform but then you could
also stream it to all the other people
as well
so it could they have they have a
marketplace they have a massive massive
marketplace then they have
infrastructure in place to be able to
connect
these people to one another i i don't
think it's the horrible idea that
boomers think it is i really don't
you know what they're they're they've
got their work cut out for them in the
streaming wars
i mean now that discovery has has paired
up with warner yep
um and there's some some cup and they're
chasing uh disney right now
they're gonna be chasing amazon soon
they have to do something that's gonna
differentiate
they haven't been profitable ever let me
ask you questions so what are they gonna
do let's just say they don't do anything
what are they gonna do they're gonna
keep doing this and they're to keep
doubling that who else has done it
with that model i mean i understand
staying specialized
for a decade or two i fully get that i
think there's strength and staying
specialized for a while but
who has state specialized for 100 years
who has they specialized for 50 years
who has did amazon stay specialized for
15. for 20 years no
did walmart state specialize walmart
stay specialized for about 50 years but
look what walmart's been doing right so
they're looking at everybody google is
probably the one that's
the most specialized they tried a couple
different things google plus didn't work
out for them
go facebook fairly specialized but they
bought whatsapp they bought instagram
they bought
a few different things if you go and
look at the model where they're at
and you're talking streaming where i can
play the game on netflix with 200
million users
and i can go in in a way where my risk
is not that high
i don't know i think for netflix the
next move could be
like remember used to go to blockbuster
and used to go to blockbuster to buy
what
movies yep but what did they do they
came up with their games
and it actually worked it worked for
blockbuster blockbuster didn't have
their late fee
debacle going back and forth blockbuster
could still be around today
and you know if they would have i
couldn't afford to buy video games when
i was a kid but i could afford
to rent the game for five bucks five
bucks yeah so the games
so i think i think there is a business
model for what netflix wants
i'll tell you what else i'll tell you
what else too man the the concept of
um microsoft if i remember correctly we
have to go back and check but i remember
when microsoft said that they were going
to get in the gaming they caught the
same pushback
they said you guys are business software
what do you know about gaming
you're going to get destroyed nintendo's
been doing this for 20 years sony you
know and
and now without xbox where would
microsoft be
like xbox is is probably more than half
their company that's right yeah but
that's a
that's a piece of equipment too right
this isn't just
what what netflix is talking about doing
is virtual and streaming
they were a software company and they
became a hardware company it does is
that
that even decreases the risk anything
that's more physical you got more work
manufacturing
warehouse all of that stuff you need to
do if it's going to be virtual it's a
lot easier to take that risk i don't
know
if you're watching this if you're
watching this if you think netflix id is
a good idea
smash thumbs up like meaning them going
into gaming if you're saying
absolute terrible idea i'm a netflixer
and i would never want to have video
games i play my video games on twitch
and i go watch my videos on netflix let
us know put thumbs down so good idea
thumbs up
bad eye the person we should talk to is
curt schilling curt schilling blew his
entire major league salary
on trying to start a game remember that
and he got he got the big loan from the
state
oh yeah he did he he made 50 million
disappear more than uh
if we had a podcast back in the day when
that happened and because they bailed
them out
yeah they gave him this huge they gave
him like his whole fortune was gone
yeah they uh does he still have money
today he has his pension
so he gets like what is that big league
punch is what ten thousand times i'm in
the moment
trying to start a major gaming company
150 million and schilling was
a world series this guy was did he win
the scion he should be a hall of famer
he's not a conservative so they're not
going to put him in did he win
oh yeah multiple times or one well he
won the world series one time cy young
but multiple times he's one of the best
pitchers in there's no question he was a
big game pitcher
yeah very interesting so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye